rallying outside Parliament for a second
night in a row
protesters in tibilisi have been
marching against a so-called foreign
agent spill that many fear will curtail
civil liberties and stifle press freedom
but right police pushed them back using
tear gas water cannon and stunt grenades
the transparency of foreign funding bill
passed a first reading in Parliament on
Tuesday but not without chaos and
fighting between MPS
[Applause]
the bill requires ngos and media Outlets
receiving more than 20 percent of their
funding from abroad to register as
foreign agents or face heavy fines
president
has come out in support of protesters
and has vowed to veto the bill
many demonstrators say the bill is
reminiscent of Russian legislation used
to silence critics
they say should the bill become law it
will ruin Georgia's chances of becoming
a member of the European Union and NATO
around 80 percent of Georgian population
still is very Pro Western and they see
their future in West so that's very
important for our government as we see
to demonize these people and to to
damage the reputation of the
organizations of donors of those who
work with them and to isolate Georgia
the draft is backed by the governing
Georgian Dream party and says it would
allow for transparency of foreign
influence
prime minister irately Gary bashvili
says it will help root out those working
against Georgia's interests but critics
say that's not the case the theory
amongst many Georgians that this is
actually a conscious effort by Georgia
Florida's government to sabotage
Georgia's efforts to join the EU in
order to to sort of carry favor with the
Kremlin and avoid a military uh
intervention like we saw in Ukraine and
Georgians are very angry about this uh
precisely because uh Georgia is such a
pro-european country and they're very
anti-russian country in terms of public
opinion more than 60 independent and
Civil Society organizations have said
they will not comply with the bill if
signed into law
Al Jazeera